they start from the basics
deep learning is inspired by
what people observe about the brain but
the inspiration is just an inspiration
it's not the attempt is not to copy the
brain because
there's a lot of details about the brain
that are irrelevant and that we don't
know if they are relevant actually to
human intelligence so the inspiration is
at kind of a conceptual level
and
it's a little bit the same as you know
airplanes being inspired by birds but
the underlying principles of flight for
birds and airplanes are essentially the
same but the details are extremely
different they both have wings they both
generate lift by propelling themselves
to air but you know airplanes don't have
feathers and don't flap their wings so
it's a bit the same uh the same same
idea and the the history of this goes
back to
a field
uh that has kind of almost disappeared
or at least changed name now called
cybernetics uh if you want a specialist
about the history of cybernetics he's
sitting right there
uh
joe lamelin
here raise your hand
so joe is actually a philosopher and
he's interested in he actually has a
seminar
uh on kind of the history of ai uh
in the
in what department this is
media culture and communication so not
cs
and uh uh he knows everything about you
know the history of cybernetics so it
started in the in the 40s with uh
two gentlemen uh mcculloch and pitts
their picture is on the
top right here
uh and they came up with the idea that
uh
uh you know people at the time were you
know interested in logic but
neuroscience was a very sort of nascent
uh field and they got the idea that if
neurons
are are basically threshold units that
are on or off
then by connecting neurons with each
other you can build boolean circuits and
you can basically do logical inference
with neurons and so they say you know
the brain is basically a logical
inference machines machine because the
the neurons are binary and this idea
so the idea was that a neuron
computes a weighted sum of its inputs
and then compares the weighted sum to a
threshold it turns on
if it's above the threshold turns off if
it's if it's below uh which is sort of a
simplified view of how real neurons work
a very very simplified view
that model kind of stuck with the field
for decades
like almost four decades
actually
a full four decades uh then there was
you know quasi-simultaneously donald
hebb who had the idea that
uh neurons in the brain
i mean it's an old idea that uh the
brain learns by modifying the strength
of the connections between the between
the neurons that are called the synapses
and he had the idea of what's what's now
called hebrew learning which is that if
two neurons fire together then they're
the connection that links them
uh increases and if they don't fire
together maybe it decreases
um
that's not an idea for a learning
algorithm but it's sort of a first
idea perhaps
um and then cybernetics uh was proposed
by this guy nobody winner who is
here
and this is the whole idea that by
having systems that kind of have sensors
uh and can and have actuator
you can have like feedback loops and you
can have you know self-regulating
systems and what's the theory behind
this you know we sort of take that for
granted now but uh the idea that
uh you know you have things like kind of
uh for example uh
you know you drive your car right you
you turn the wheel
and uh there's a so-called pid
controller that actually turns the wheel
in in proportion to how you turn the
steering wheel
uh and it's a feedback mechanism that
basically measures the position of the
steering wheel measures the position of
the
of the wheel of the car and then if
there is a difference between the two
kind of corrects the wheels of the car
so that they match the orientation
steering wheel that's the feedback
mechanism that the stability of this and
the rules about this are basically all
come from initially from uh from this
work
uh that led to
a gentleman by the the name of frank
rosenblatt to basically imagine
learning algorithms that modified the
weights of very simple neural nets and
what you see here at the bottom
uh
uh the two pictures here this is frank
rosenblatt and this is the the
perceptron this was a physical
analog computer it was not a
three-line python program
which is what it is now um
it was a gigantic machine with you know
wires and
optical sensors you could show it
pictures it was very low resolution
and then it had uh it would you know it
could it had neurons that could compute
a weighted sum and the weights could be
adapted and the weights were
potentiometers the potentiometers had
motors on them so they could rotate for
the learning algorithm so there was
electromechanical and what is holding
here in this end is a module of eight
weights
with uh you can count them
with those potentiometers motorized
potentiometers on them
okay so
there was a little bit of history of
where neural nets come from
another interesting piece of history is
that this whole idea of sort of trying
to build intelligent machines by
basically simulating networks of neurons
was born in the 40s kind of took off a
little bit in the late 50s and
completely died in the 1960s in the late
1960s when people realized that with the
kind of learning algorithms and
architectures that people were proposing
at the time
you couldn't do much
you know you could do some basic very
simple pattern recognition but you can
do much
so between
1969 roughly and
or 1968
and
1984 i would say
basically nobody in the world was
working on
neural nets
except
a few kind of isolated researchers
mostly in japan
because japan has its own kind of
relatively isolated ecosystem for
funding research
people don't listen to
the same kind of
fashions if you want
and then the field took off again
in 1985 roughly with the
emergence of back propagation so back
propagation is
an algorithm for training multi-layer
neural nets as you as many of you know
and people were looking for something
like this in the 60s and basically
didn't find it and the reason they
didn't find it was because they had the
wrong neurons
they were using
maculoptics neurons that are binary
and the way to get back propagation to
work
is to use an activation function that is
continuous
differentiable or at least continuous
and and people just didn't have
the
you know the idea of using continuous
neurons
and so they didn't think that you could
train those systems with
uh great understand because things were
not differentiable
now there's another reason for this
which is that if you have a neural net
with binary neurons
you never need to do you never need to
compute multiplications you never need
to multiply two numbers you only need to
add numbers right if your neuron is
active you just add the weight to the
weighted sum
if it's inactive you don't do anything
if you have continuous neurons you need
to multiply the activation of a neuron
by weight to get to get a contribution
to the weighted sum it turns out before
the 1980s multiplying two numbers
particularly floating point numbers
on any sort of non-ridiculously
expensive computer was extremely slow
and so there was an incentive to not use
uh continuous neurons for that reason
so the reason why backdrop didn't emerge
earlier than the the mid 80s is because
that's when you know
computers became fast enough to do
floating point multiplications
pretty much
people didn't think of it this way but
that's you know kind of retrospectively
that's pretty much what happened
um
so
there was a wave of interest in neural
nets between 1985 and 1995 lasted about
10 years in 1995 he died again people in
machine learning uh basically abandoned
the idea of using neural nets uh for
reasons that i'm not going to go into
right now
and that lasted until
the late 2000s early 2010 so when around
2009 2010 people realized that you could
use multi-layer neural nets train with
backprop
and get an improvement for speech
recognition it didn't start with
imagenet it started with speech
recognition around 2010
and within 18 months of the first papers
being published on this
every major player in speech recognition
had deployed commercial speech
recognition systems that use
neural nets
so if you had an android phone and you
were using any of the speech recognition
features in an android phone around 2012
that used neural net that was probably
the first really really wide
deployment of kind of modern forms of
deep learning if you want
then at the end of 2012 early 2013 the
same thing happened in computer vision
where the computer vision community
realized uh deep learning convolutional
nets in particular work much better than
whatever it is that they were using
before and started to switch using
convolutional nets and basically abandon
all previous techniques so that created
the second revolution now in computer
vision
and then three years later around 2016
or so
the same thing happened in natural
language processing in language
translation and things like this 2015-16
and now we're going to see it's not
happened yet but we're going to see the
same revolution occur
in things like robotics and and control
and you know a whole bunch of
application areas
um
but let me get to this
okay uh so you all know what supervised
running is i'm sure
uh and this is really what the
vast majority and not the vast majority
like
90 some percent applications of deep
learning use supervised running as kind
of the main uh the main thing so
supervised running is the process by
which
you collect a bunch of pairs of inputs
and outputs
of examples of let's say images together
with a category if you want to do image
recognition or a bunch of
audio clips with their text
transcription a bunch of text in one
language whether transcription in
another language etc
and you feed uh one example to the
machine it produces an output if the
output is correct you don't do anything
or you don't do much if the output is
incorrect then you tweak the parameters
of the machine think of it as a
parameterized uh function of some kind
and you tweak the parameters of that
function in such a way that the output
gets closer to the one you want okay
this is a non-technical term what
supervision is all about
so show a picture of a car if the system
doesn't say car tweak the
parameters the parameters in the neural
net are going to be the weights on the
you know the compute weighted sums in in
those sort of simulated neurons
uh tweak the
the knob so that the output gets closer
to the one you want
uh the trick in neural net is how do you
figure out in which direction and how
much to tweak the knob so that the
output gets closer to the one you want
that's what gradient competition and
back propagation is about
but before we get to this
a little bit a little bit of history
again so there was a flurry of models
basic models for
classification you know starting with a
perceptron there was another competing
model called the adeline which is on the
top right here uh based on the same kind
of basic architectures computer weighted
sum of inputs compared to a threshold if
it's above the threshold uh turn on if
it's below the threshold turn off
uh what you see the the the adder line
here the the thing that bernie we draw
is tw is tweaking is actually a physical
analog computer again um so it's like
like like the perceptron it was much
less you know much smaller
in many ways
and the reason i'm telling you about
this is that the the perceptron actually
was a two-layer neural net a two-layer
neural net in which the second layer was
trainable
with adaptive weights but the first
layer was fixed in fact most of the time
with most experiments it was it was
it was determined randomly you would
like randomly connect
uh input pixels of an image to
uh neurons that would you know be
threshold neurons with random weights
essentially
uh this is what they call the
associative layer
and that basically uh uh
became the basis for the sort of
conceptual design of a pattern
recognition system for the next four
decades
um
i want to say four decades
yeah pretty much
so
so that model is one by which you you
take an input you run it through a
feature extractor that is supposed to
extract the relevant
characteristics of the input that would
be useful for the task
um so you want to recognize a face can
you detect an eye how do you detect an
eye well there is probably a dark circle
somewhere
things like that right you want to
recognize a car you know are there kind
of dark round things
et cetera
so the problem here and so what the
future extractor produces is a vector of
features which are things that may be
numbers or they may be on or off okay so
it's just a list of numbers a vector
and you're going to feed that vector to
a trainable classifier in the case of
perceptron or simple neural net it's
going to be just
a system that computes a weighted sum
compares it to a threshold
and
the problem is that you have to engineer
the feature extractor so the entire
literature
of pattern recognition statistical
pattern recognition at least
and a lot of computer vision at least
the part of computer vision that's
interested in recognition was focused on
this part the feature extractor how do
you design a feature extractor for a
particular problem you want to do i
don't know how google character
recognition what are the relevant uh
features for recognizing google and how
can you extract them using all kinds of
algorithmic tricks uh how do you
pre-process the images you know about
how you normalize their size you know
things like that how do you skeletonize
them how do you segment them from their
background so the entire literature was
devoted to this very very little was
devoted to that
and what uh what deep learning brought
to the table is this idea that instead
of having this kind of two-stage process
for pattern recognition where one stage
is built by hand
but the representation of the input is
the result of uh you know some hand
engineered program essentially
the idea of deep learning is that you
learn the entire task end-to-end
okay so basically you build your
uh pattern recognition system or
whatever it is that you want to do with
it
as a cascade or sequence
of modules all of those modules have
tunable parameters
all of them have some sort of
non-linearity in them
okay and then you stack them you stack
multiple layers of them which is why
it's called deep learning so the only
reason for the deep word in deep
learning is the fact that there are
multiple layers there's nothing more to
that
okay and then you train the entire thing
end to end so the complication here of
course is the fact that uh
the parameters that are in the first box
how do you know how to turn them so that
the output does you know goes closer to
the
output you want
that's that's what backpropagation does
for you
okay why do all those modules
have to be
non-linear it's because if you have two
two successive modules and they're both
linear you can collapse them into a
single linear
right the product of two linear
functions or the composition of two
linear functions is a linear function
take a vector multiplied by a matrix and
then multiply by a second matrix
it's as if you had precomputed the
product of those two matrices and then
multiplied the input vector by
that
uh
composite matrix so there's no point
having multiple layers if those layers
are linear
okay
it's actually a point but
it's a minor point
so
since they have to be non-linear what is
the simplest
multi-layer architecture you can imagine
that has
parameters that you can tune things like
weights in the neural nets
and is non-linear
and you realize quickly that
it has to look something like this
so
take an input an input can be
represented as a vector right an image
is just a list of numbers
think of it as a vector you know the
fact that it's an image for now
piece of audio whatever it is
that your your sensors or your data set
gives you
is a vector
multiply this vector by matrix the
coefficients in this matrix are the
tunable parameters
and then take the resulting vector right
when you multiply a matrix by vector you
get a vector
pass each component of this vector
through a non-linear function
and if you want to have the simplest
possible nonlinear function use
something like what's shown at the top
here which people in the in your let's
call the value people in engineering
call this halfway rectification
people in math call this positive part
whatever you want to call it okay
so apply this nonlinear function to
every component of the vector that
results from multiplying the input
vector by the matrix
okay now you get a new vector which has
lots of zeros in it because
whenever the weighted sum was
less than zero
the output is zero if you pass through
the value
and then repeat the process take that
vector multiplied by a weight matrix
pass the result through
pointwise non-linearity
take the result pass it multiply by a
matrix pass a result through
nonlinearities
that's a basic neural net essentially
okay now
why is that called a neural net at all
it's because when you take a vector and
you multiply
a vector by matrix
to compute each component of the output
you actually compute a weighted sum of
the components of the input
by a corresponding row in the matrix
right so this little symbol here there's
a bunch of
components of the vector
coming into this layer
and you take a row of the matrix
computer uh
a weighted sum of those values where the
weights are the
the values in the row of that matrix and
that gives you
a weighted sum
and you do this for every row that gives
you the
result right so the number of units
after the multiplication by a matrix is
going to be equal to the number of rows
of your matrix
and the number of columns of the matrix
of course has to be equal to the size of
the input
okay so supervised running in more
formal terms than the one i showed
earlier
is the idea by which you're going to
compare the output that the system
produces
so right you show an input you run
through the neural net you get an output
you're going to compare this output with
a target output
and you're going to have an objective
function
a loss module that computes
a distance a discrepancy
penalty whatever you want to call it
divergence okay there's various names
for it
and then you're going to compute the
average of of that so that's the output
of this cost function is a scalar right
it computes the distance for example
euclidean distance between a target
vector and the vector that uh the neural
net produces
deep learning system produces
and then you can compute the average of
this cost function which is just a
scalar
you're going to average it over a
training set right so a training set is
composed of a bunch of pairs of inputs
and outputs compute the average of this
over the training set
the function you want to minimize with
respect to the parameters of the system
the tunable knobs
is that average
okay so you want to find the value of
the parameters that minimizes the
average error between the
output you want and the output you get
averaged over a training set of samples
so
i'm sure you know the vast majority of
people here sort of have at least some
intuitive understanding of what gradient
descent is so basically the way to
minimize this is to compute a gradient
right so
it's like you are uh in the mountain
you're lost in the mountain and uh it's
a very smooth mountain but
there's fog and it's night
and you want to go to the village in the
valley
and so
the best thing you can do is
you you turn around and you see which
way is down and you take a step down
in the direction of steepest descent
okay
so this search for the direction that
goes down that's called computing a
gradient or technically a negative
gradient
okay then you take a step down that's
taking a step down in the
direction of negative gradient and if
you keep doing this and your steps are
small enough
uh small enough so that when you take a
step you don't jump to the other side of
the mountain then
eventually you're going to convert to
the valley
if
the valley is convex which means that if
there is no kind of
lake no mountain lakes in the middle
where you know there's kind of a
minimum and you're going to get stuck in
that minimum the value might be lower
but you don't see it
okay
so that's why complexity
is important as a concept
um but uh here is another concept which
is the the concept of stochastic
gradient which i'm sure again a lot of
you have heard i'll come back to that um
in more detail
this uh the objective function you're
computing is an average over many many
samples and you can compute the
objective function in this gradient
over the entire training set
by averaging
the the value of the entire training set
but it turns out it's more efficient to
just take one sample or a small group of
samples
computing the error that
this sample makes then computing the
gradient of that error with respect to
the parameters and taking a step
a small step
then a new
sample comes in you're going to get
another
value for the error and another value
for the gradient which may be in a
different direction because it's a
different sample
and take a step in that direction
and if you keep doing this you're going
to
go down the
uh the cost surface but in kind of a
noisy way there's going to be a lot of
fluctuations
so what is shown here is an example of
this this is stochastic gradient applied
to a very simple problem with two
dimensions where you only have two
weights
and it looks kind of semi-periodic
because the examples are always shown in
the same order which is not what you're
supposed to do is to catch the gradient
but as you can see the path is really
erratic why do people use this there's
various reasons
one reason is that empirically it
converges much much faster particularly
if you have a very large training set
and the other reason is that you
actually get better generalization in
the end so if you measure the
performance of the system on a separate
set that you
you know i assume you all know the
concept of training set and test sets
and validation set but
um so if you test the performance of the
system on a different set you get
generally better generalization if you
use the casting gradient and if you
actually use the real true gradient
descent
uh the problem is yes
sir if it was computationally possible
to
run gradient descent
no
it's worse so computing the entire
gradient of the entire data set
it is computationally feasible
i mean you can do it it's
not any more expensive than
um
you know more than it would be less
noisy less it'd be noise
so let me tell you why i mean this is
something we're going to talk about
again when we talk about optimization
but let me tell you i give you a
training set with a million training
samples and it's actually
100 repetitions of the same training
sample with 10 000 samples okay so my
actual sample is ten thousand training
samples
and uh i i replicate it a hundred times
and i and i claim that you know i
scramble it
and i tell you
here is my training set with a million
training samples
so if you do a full gradient you're
going to
compute the same values 100 times you're
going to spend 100 times more work than
necessary
without knowing it
okay so this only works because of
repetition but it also also works in
kind of more normal situations of
machine learning where you have samples
that are
have a lot of uh
redundance in them like very many
samples are very similar to each other
etc so there is any kind of coherence
if your system is capable of
generalization then that means
stochastic gradient is going to be more
efficient because uh it's good if you
don't use the case equation you're not
going to be able to take advantage of
that redundancy
so that's one case where noise is good
for you
okay um
don't pay attention to the formula don't
don't get scared because we're going to
come back to this in more details
but uh why is back propagation called
back propagation
and again this is very informal
it's basically a practical application
of chain rule so you can think of
a neural network type that i showed
earlier as a bunch of modules that are
stacked on top of each other and you can
think of this as compositions of
functions
and you all know the basic rule of
calculus you know how you compute the
derivative of a function composed with
another function
well the derivative of you know
f composed with g is the
derivative of f at the point of g of x
multiplied by the derivative of g at the
point x right so you get the product of
the two
derivatives so this is the same thing
except that the function instead of
being scalar functions are vector
functions they get vectors as inputs and
they produce vectors as outputs more
generally actually they take
multi-dimensional arrays as inputs and
multi-dimensional arrays at output but
doesn't matter
and basically what is the generalization
of this chain rule
uh
in the case of
uh
kind of functional modules that have
multiple inputs multiple outputs that
you can view as functions right
um and basically the
it's the same world if you kind of
blindly apply them it's the same rule as
you applied for
uh as you apply for regular derivatives
uh except here you have to use partial
derivatives but uh
uh you know
what you what you see in the end is that
if you want to compute the derivative
of the difference between the output you
want and the output you get which is the
value of your objective function with
respect to any variable inside of the
network
then you have to kind of back you know
propagate derivatives backwards and kind
of multiply things on the way
all right
we'll be much more formal about this
next week for now
you just know why
it's called back propagation and because
it applies to multiple layers
um
okay so
the
the pictures i showed earlier of this
neural net
uh is nice but
what if the input is actually an image
right so an image
even sort of a relatively low resolution
image is typically
like you know a few hundred pixels on
the side
okay so let's say
256 by 256 to take a random example okay
a color image 256.56
so it's got 65 536 pixels times three
because you have rg and b components to
it for you know you have three value for
each pixels
and so that's you know roughly 200 000
values
okay so your vector here
is a vector with 200 000 components
if you have a matrix that is going to
multiply this vector this matrix is
going to have to have 200 000 rows
uh columns i'm sorry
and depending on how many units you have
here in the first layer there's going to
be a 200 000 by
you know maybe a large number that's a
huge matrix right even it's 200 000 by
100 000 so you have a
compression in the first layer
uh
you know that's
that's already a lot of
a very very large matrix billions
so it's not really practical to think of
this as a full matrix what you're going
to have to do if you want to deal with
things like images
is make some hypothesis about the
structure of this matrix so that it's
not a completely full matrix that you
know
connects everything to everything
that would be impractical
at least for a lot of practical
applications
so this is where inspiration from the
brain comes back
there was some work uh classic work in
uh in neuroscience in the 1960s by the
gentleman at the top here uh huber and
weasel they actually won the nobel prize
for this in the in the 70s but their
work was from the late 50s early 60s and
what they did was that they poked
electrode in electrodes in the visual
cortex of various animals you know cats
monkeys
mice you know whatever
i think they like cats a lot
um
and they tried to figure out
what the neurons
in the visual cortex were doing
and what they discovered was that
so first of all well this is a human
brain but i mean this chart is for much
later but
all mammalian
visual system is organized in similar
way
you have signals coming into your eyes
striking your retina you have a few
layers of neurons in your retina in
front of your photoreceptors that kind
of pre-process the
the signal if you want they kind of
compress it because you can't have
uh you know the human eye as uh
something like 100 million pixels
so it's like 100 megapixel camera
megapixel camera
but the problem is you cannot have 100
million fibers coming out of your eye
because otherwise your optical nerve
would be this big
and you wouldn't be able to move your
eyes
um
so those neurons in front of your retina
do
compression they don't do jpeg
compression but they do compression
so that the signal can be compressed to
one million fibers right so you have one
million fibers coming out of each of
your eyes
and that makes your you know optical
nerve about this big which means you
know you can
carry the signal and turn your eyes
uh this is actually a mistake that
evolution made
for vertebrates
um
invertebrates are not like that
invertebrates have actually so it's a
big mistake because
the wires collecting the information
from your from your retina
uh
because the neurons that process the
signal are in front of your retina
the wires have to kind of
uh
you know be in front of your retina it's
a blocking part of the view if you want
and then they have to punch a hole
through your retina to get through your
brain
so there's a blind spot in your visual
field because that's where your optical
nerve punches through your retina
um so it's kind of ridiculous if you
have a camera like this to have the
wires coming out the front and then you
know dig a hole in your sensor to get
the wires back it's much better if the
wires come out the back right
and very bright got that wrong
invertebrate got it right so
uh
you know like squids and octopus
actually have wires coming out the back
they're much luckier
um but anyway
um
so the signal goes from your your eyes
to a little
piece of brain called the lateral
geniculate nucleus which is under your
brain actually and like at the basis of
it
it does a little bit of
contrast normalization we'll talk about
this
uh again in a few lectures
uh
and and then that goes to the back of
your brain where the the primary visual
cortex area called v1 uh
is it's called v1 in humans
and there's uh something called the
ventral hierarchy v1 v2 v4 it which is a
bunch of brain areas going from the back
to the side
and in the uh if our temporal cortex
right here this is where object
categories are represented so
when you go around and you see your
grandmother you have a bunch of neurons
firing that represent your grandmother
in this area and it doesn't matter what
your grandmother is wearing
uh you know what what position she is in
if there is occlusion or whatever those
neurons will fire if you see your
grandmother
um
so the sort of category level
uh things and and those things have been
discovered by experiments with uh
patients that had to have their skull
open for a few weeks
and uh where you know people poked
electrodes and had them watch movies and
realize this is normal that turns on if
jennifer aniston is on the movie and it
only turns on for jennifer aniston
so
with the
idea that somehow the visual cortex you
know can do pattern recognition and
seems to have this sort of hierarchical
structure
multi-layer structure
there's also the idea that the visual
process is essentially a feed-forward
process so the process by which you
recognize everything object
is very fast it takes about 100
milliseconds and it's barely enough time
for the signal to go from your retina to
your infra-temporal cortex it takes
about you know it's a few millisecond
delays per neuron that you have to go
through 100 milliseconds you barely have
time to for just you know a few spikes
to go through the to the entire system
so there's no time for like you know
recurrent connections and like you know
etc doesn't mean that there are no
record connections there's tons of them
but somehow
fast recognition is done without them
so this is called the the the feed
forward ventral pathway
and this gentleman uh here couldn't
fukushima had the idea of taking
inspiration from
weasel in the 70s and sort of build a
neural net model on the computer that
had this idea that
first there were layers but also the
idea that hubert and weasel discovered
that individual neurons only react to a
small part of the visual field
so they put electrode in
neurons in v1 and they realize that this
neuron in v1 only reacts to
motifs that appear in a very small area
in the visual field
and then the neural next to it will
react to another
area that's next to the first one
right so the neurons seem to be
organized in what's called a retinotopic
way which means that neighboring neurons
react to neighboring regions
in the visual field what they also
realize is that the groups of neurons
all react to the same area in the visual
field and they seem to turn on for
edges at a particular orientation so one
neuron will turn on for if uh its uh
receptive field has an edge a vertical
edge and then the one next to it if the
edge is a little slanted and then one
next to it if the edge is a little
rotated etc
um
and so they had this picture of
v1 basically as oriented orientation
selectivity so neurons that look at a
local
field and then react to orientations and
those groups of neurons that react to
multiple orientations are replicated
over the entire visual field
so this guy fukushima said well why
don't i build a neural net that does
this i'm not gonna
you know necessarily insist that my
system extracts oriented uh features but
i'm gonna use some sort of unsupervised
learning algorithm to
um to train it so he was not training
his system end-to-end he was training it
layer by layer in some sort of
unsupervised fashion uh which i'm not
going to go into the details of
um
and then he used another concept from
so you see the concept that those
neurons were replicated across the his
visual field
and then use another concept for for
from uber and result called complex
cells so complex cells are units that
pool the activities of a bunch of simple
cells which are the those oriented uh
orientation selective units
and
they pull them in such a way that
if an orientation if an oriented edge is
moved a little bit
it will activate different simple cells
but the complex cell since it integrates
the outputs from all those simple cells
will will stay activated
until the edge moves beyond its uh
receptive field
so
those complex cells build a little bit
of shifting variance in the
representation you can shift an edge a
little bit and it will not change the
activation the activity of one of those
complex cells
so that's
uh
what we now call uh convolutional
pulling in the comp in the context of
convolutional nets
that basically is what
led me in the mid 80s and late 80s to uh
come up with computational net so
they're basically
networks
where the connections are local
they are replicated across the visual
field
and you you uh
intersperse uh
sort of feature detection layers that
detect those focal features with pooling
operation we'll talk about this at
length uh you know in in three weeks so
i'm not going to go to into every detail
but um but it has um you recycle this
idea from uber and visual and fukushima
that um
if i can get my pointer
that basically every neuron in one layer
computes a weighted sum of a small area
of the input
and
the weighted sum uses those weights
those weights are replicated across so
every neuron in a layer use the same
set of weights okay so the idea of
weight tying or weight sharing
um
so we're using backpack we're able to
train neural nets like this to recognize
uh
handwritten digits this is back from the
late 80s early 90s
and
this is me when i was about your age
maybe a little older i'm about 30
the video
and this is my phone number when i was
working at bell labs
uh it doesn't work anymore it's a new
jersey number
and i hit a key and this is neural net
running on a 386 pc with a special
accelerator card recognizing those
characters running a neural net very
similar to the one i just show you the
animation of
and this thing could
you know recognize characters of any
style
um
including very strange styles
including even stranger styles
um and so this was kind of new at the
time because
this was back when
uh character recognition or pattern
recognition in general we're still in
the model of we extract features and
then we turn a classifier on top and
this could basically train the entire
like learn the entire task from end to
end uh you know basically the first few
layers of that neural net would would
play the role of a feature extractor but
it was trained from data
the reason why we used character
recognition is because this was uh this
was the only thing for which we had data
the only task for which there was enough
data was either character recognition or
speech recognition speech recognition
experiments were somewhat successful but
not as much
uh pretty quickly we realized we could
use those uh
conditional nets not just to recognize
individual characters but to recognize
groups of characters so multiple
characters at a single time and it's
because of this convolutional nature of
the network which i'll come back to in
three lectures
that uh basically allow those systems to
just
you know be applied to a large image and
then they will just
turn on whatever they see
in their uh
field of view whether they see a a shape
that they can recognize
so basically if you have a large image
you you train a condition that has a
small input window and you swipe it over
the entire image and whenever it turns
on it's mean it's detected
uh the object that you trained it to
detect
so here the system you know is capable
of doing cemeteries segmentation and
recognition you know back in the uh
before that people in pattern
recognition would have an explicit
program that would separate individual
objects from their background and from
each other and then send each individual
object character for example to a
recognizer
but with this you could you can do both
at the same time you don't have to worry
about it you don't have to build a new
special program for it
um so in particular this could be
applied to natural images for things
like like face phase detection
pedestrian detection things like this
right same thing train a
conventional net to
distinguish between an image where you
have a face an image where you don't
have a face train this with several
thousand examples
and then take that window swipe it over
an image whenever it turns on there is a
face
of course the face could be bigger than
the window so you sample the image you
make it smaller and you swipe your
network again and then make it smaller
again swipe your network again so now
you can detect faces regardless of size
okay
in particular you can use this to drive
robots so this is things that were done
before deep learning became popular okay
so this is an example where the the
network here is a commercial net it's
applied to the image coming from a
camera from a
you know running robot
and it's trying to classify
every window of a small window like 40
by 40 pixels or so even less
as to whether the central pixel in that
window is on the ground or is an
obstacle right so whatever it classifies
as being on the ground is green whatever
it classifies as being an obstacle is
red or purple if it's on the foot of the
obstacle
and then you can sort of map this to
a map which you see at the top
and then do planning in this map to
reach a particular goal and then use
this to navigate
and so these are two former phd students
raya had cell on the right piercer mne
on the left
or annoying this poor robot
pretty confident the robot is not going
to break their legs
since they actually wrote the code and
trained it
uh piazza male is a research scientist
at google brain in california working on
robotics
raya hatsell is
head of robotics research at the
director of robotics research at
deepmind
did it pretty well
so a similar idea can be used for what's
called semantic segmentation so semantic
segmentation is the idea that you can
again with this kind of sliding window
approach
you can train a convolutional net to
classify the central pixel using a
window as a context
uh but here it's not just uh trained to
classify
obstacle from an obstacles it's trying
to classify something like 30 categories
this is uh sit down uh
washington place i think this is
washington square park
uh and it you know it knows about roads
and
people and plants and
trees and whatever
but it finds you know desert in the
middle of washington square park which
is not
there's no beach that i'm aware of um
so it's not perfect at the time it was
state of the art though that was the
best
system there was to do this kind of
semantic segmentation
i was running around giving talks like
trying to evangelize people about deep
learning back then this was around 2010.
so it's before the kind of deep learning
revolution if you want
and uh
and when one person a professor from uh
um
israel was sitting in one of my my talks
and
he's a theoretician but he was really
kind of transfixed by the potential
applications of this and he was just
about to take a sabbatical and work for
a company called mobileye which was a
startup in israel at the time
working on autonomous driving
and so
a couple months after you heard my talk
he started working at mobileye and he
told the mobile people
you know you should try this
convolutional net stuff this works
really well
and the engineers that say
you know we don't believe in that stuff
we have our own method
um so he
implemented it and tried it himself beat
the hell out of
all the benchmarks they had and all of a
sudden the whole company switched to
using commercial nets
and they were the first company to
actually come up with
a
vision system
for cars that you know can keep a car on
a highway and can break if there is a
pedestrian or
or a cyclist uh dr uh crossing i'll come
back to this in a minute
they were basically using this technique
um semantic segmentation very similar to
the one i showed for the robot before
this is not clement this was a guy by
the name of uh
uh shysha left watts
um
you have to be aware of the fact also
that back in the 80s people were really
interested in using in sort of
implementing special types of hardware
that could run neural nets really fast
and these are kind of a few examples of
neural net chips that were actually
implemented
i had to do with some of them but they
were implemented by people working in
the same group as i was
as i was at bell labs in new jersey
so this was kind of a hot topic in the
1980s and then of course with the
interesting neural net dying in the in
the mid 90s people weren't working on
this anymore
until a few years ago now
the hottest topic in
in chip design in the ship industry is
neural net accelerators
you go to any conference on
computer architecture
uh
you know
chip
like isscc which is the big kind of
solid state circuit conference
half the talks are about
neural net accelerators
and i worked on a few of those things
um
okay so then
something happened as i told you around
2010 1315
in speech recognition image recognition
natural language processing and it's and
it's continuing we're in the middle of
it now for other topics
um
and what happened and i'm
really uh sad to say it didn't happen in
my lab but um
but with our friends
uh we started uh with joshua banjo and
jeff intern back in the early 2000's
we knew you know
that that deep learning was working
really well
and we knew that the whole community was
making a mistake by dismissing neural
nets and deep learning and so
we didn't use the term deep learning yet
we invented it a few years later so
around 2003 or so 2004 we started kind
of a conspiracy if you want we got
together and we said we're just going to
try to kind of beat some records on some
data sets invent some new algorithms
again it will allow us to train very
large neural nets so that we'll and
we'll collect very large data sets so
that we will show the world that those
things really work because nobody really
believed it
um
and that really kind of succeeded beyond
our or what does dreams in particular in
2012 jeff hinton had one student alex
krajewski who spent a lot of time
implementing convolutional nets
on gpus which were kind of new at the
time they were not entirely new but
they're starting to become really
high performance
so he was very good at sort of
hacking that and
and then they were able to train much
larger neural net convolutional nets
that anybody was able to do before
and so they used it to to uh
to train on the imagenet data set the
imagenet data set is a bunch of natural
photos
and the system is supposed to
recognize
the main object in the photo among uh
1000 different categories
and the training set had 1.3 million
samples
which is
kind of large
so what they did was uh build this
really large and very deep
convolutional net very much on the same
model as what we had before implemented
on gpus and let it run
for a couple weeks
and with that they beat
the performance of best computing
systems
by a large margin so this is the error
rate on image net going back to 2010
so 2010 it was about 28 error top five
so basically you get an error if the
correct category is not in the top five
among one thousand
okay so it's kind of a mild
uh
measure of uh of error
2011 it was 25.8
the the system that was able to do this
was actually very very large
um it was sort of somewhat
conventional net like but it wasn't
trained i mean only the last layer was
trained
um
and then uh
jeff and his team got it down to 16.4
percent and then
there was a
watershed moment for the computer vision
community a lot of people said okay you
know now we know that this thing works
and the whole community went from
basically refusing every paper that had
neural nets in them in 2011
and 2012
to refusing every paper that does not
have a convolutional net in it
in 2016.
um so now it's the new religion right
you can't get a paper in a computer
vision conference unless you use content
somehow
and the error rate went down really
quickly you know people found all kinds
of really cute architectural tricks
uh that sort of made those things work
better and what you'd seen there is that
there was uh an inflation of the number
of layers so my convolutional nets from
the 90s had seven layers or so
and from the early 2000s and then
uh alexnet had i don't know 12
then vgg the year afterward after that
at 19
uh google net had i don't know how many
because it's hard to figure out how you
count
and then the workhorse now of
object recognition the standard uh
backbone as people call them has 50
layers
it's called resnet50
but some you know some networks have 100
layers or so so alfredo a few years ago
put together this chart
that shows
uh
where each of those blob is a
particular network architecture
and the x-axis is the number of billions
of operations you need to do to compute
the output
okay those things are really big
billions of
connections the y-axis is the top one
accuracy on imagenet so it's not the
same measure of performance as the one i
showed you before
so the best systems are around 84 today
and the size of the of the blob is the
memory occupancy so
the
number of
millions of uh
floats that you need to store to store
the weight the weight values now people
are very smart about compressing those
things like you know quantizing them and
these entire teams at google facebook
and various other places that only work
on optimizing those networks and
compressing
the
things so they can run fast
because
uh to give you just a
a rough idea
uh the number of times
facebook for example runs a
convolutional net on its servers per day
is in the tens of billions
okay so
there's a huge incentive to
optimizing the amount of computation
necessary for this
so when
one reason why uh
conditional nets are being so successful
is that they exploit a property of
natural data
which is compositionality
so
compositionality is the
the property by which
a scene is composed of objects
objects are composed of parts
parts are composed of subparts subparts
are really combinations of motifs
and motifs are combinations of
contours or edges
right or textures
and those are just combinations of
pixels okay so there's this so-called
compositional hierarchy
that uh
you know particular combinations of
objects that
at one layer in the hierarchy
form
objects at the next layer
and so if you kind of mimic this
compositional hierarchy in the
architecture of the network
and you let it learn the appropriate
combinations of features or one layer
that
you know form the
the features of the next layer
that's really
what
deep learning is
okay learning to represent the world and
exploit the structure of the world and
the world being the fact that
there is organization in the world
because the world is compositional
a statistician by the name of stuart
gehmann who is at brown university said
uh so he was kind of playing on the
famous einstein quote einstein said
the most incomprehensible thing about
the world is that the world is
comprehensible
like among all the complicated things
that the world you know the world could
be extremely complicated so complicated
that we have no way of understanding it
and it looks like a conspiracy that we
are able to understand at least part of
the world
um and so stuart gaiman version of this
is that the world is compositional or
there is a god
because you need supernatural
things to be able to understand it if
the world is not compositional
so this has led to incredible progress
in things like computer vision um
as you know from
you know being able to unreliably
identify you know detect people to being
able to generate masks for every object
accurate masks and then even sort of
figure out the pose and then do this in
real time on a mobile platform you know
i mean the progress has been sort of
nothing short of incredible and most of
those things are based on uh two basic
families of architectures
the sort of so-called one pass object
detection recognition
architectures called red internet
feature pyramid network there's various
names for it or unit
and then another type called nascar cnn
both of them actually originated from
facebook
or
the people who originated to them are
now at facebook they sometimes came up
with it before they came to facebook um
but you know those things work really
well you know they can do things like
like that detect objects that are
partially occluded
and you know draw a mask of every object
so basically this is a neural net a
combination on that where the input is
an image
but the output is also an image
in fact the output is a whole bunch of
images one per category and for each
category it puts the mask of the object
from that category
those things can also do what's called
instant segmentation so if you have a
whole bunch of sheeps
uh it can tell you you know not just
that this region is cheap but actually
pick out the individual sheeps and we'll
tell them apart and then it'll count the
sheeps right and fall asleep
that's what you're supposed to do right
to fall asleep you count sheeps right
and the cool thing about deep learning
is that a lot of the community has
embraced the whole concept that research
has to be done in the open so
a lot of the stuff that we're going to
be talking about
as you probably know
in the class
is uh
is not just published but it's
you know published with code it's not
just code it's actually pre-trained
models that you can just download and
run
all open source all free to use
so that's
really new i mean people didn't use to
do research this way particularly in
industry
but even in academia people weren't used
to kind of distributing their code
but deep learning is sort of
somehow the race that's kind of driven
people to kind of be more open about
research
so there's a lot of applications of all
this uh as i said you know start driving
car this is actually a video from
mobileye and mobile was pretty early in
this using convolutional nets for
autonomous driving uh to the point that
in 2015 they
had managed to shoehorn a competition
net on the chip that they had designed
for some other purpose and they sold the
they licensed the technology to tesla so
the first self-driving teslas
um i mean self-driving not really
self-driving they're driving assistance
right they can keep in line on the
highway and change lane had this
mobilized system
uh and uh
and that's that's pretty cool so that's
a convolutional net it's a little chip
that is you know just behind the it
looks out the window and it's behind the
uh
the the rear view mirror
uh since then this you know four or five
years ago since then this kind of
technology has been uh
very widely deployed by a lot of
different companies mobilized still now
was bought by intel and they have like
70 or 80 percent of the market for those
vision systems but
but there is a lot of
companies that
and car manufacturers
that
use those things so in fact
uh in some european countries every
single car that comes out even low end
cars has a convolutional net based
vision systems and they call this uh
emerging emergency uh sort of advanced
emergency braking system or automated
emergency braking system
aebs
it's deployed in every car in france for
example
it reduces collisions by 40
uh so not every car on the roads have
them yet because you know people keep
their cars for a long time but
uh
but what that means is that it it saves
lives
so a very positive application of deep
learning
another big category of applications of
course is medical imaging so this is a
it's probably the hardest topic in
radiology these days is how do you use
ai which means convolutional nets
for for radiology
this is lifted from a paper by some of
our colleagues here at nyu
where they analyzed mri images so
there's one big advantage to commercial
nets is that they don't need to look at
the screen to
look at an mri in particular
to be able to look at an mri they don't
have to slice it into 2d images they can
look at the entire 3d value
this is
one property that this thing
uses it's a co it's a 3d compositional
net that looks at the entire volume of
an mri image
and then produces you know it uses the
very similar technique for
as i was showing before for semantic
segmentation and it produces it
basically turns on on the output image
wherever there is some
uh you know here a femur bone but you
know it could be uh
so this is the kind of result it
produces
and it works better in 3d than in 2d
slices or you can turn on when it
detects a
malignant tumor in
mammograms this is 2d it's not 3d
and there's various other projects in
medical imaging that are going around
okay
lots of applications in science in
physics bioinformatics you know whatever
which we'll come back to so
okay
so there's a bunch of mysteries in deep
learning they're not complete mysteries
because people have some understanding
of all this but there are mysteries in
the sense that we don't have like nice
theory for everything
uh
why do they work so well
so one big question that theoreticians
were asking many years ago when i was
trying to convince the world that deep
learning was a good idea was that they
would tell me well you can approximate
any function with just two layers why do
you need more
and i'll come back to this in a minute
uh what's so special about convolutional
nets um you know i talked about the
compositionality of natural images of
natural data in general it's true for
speech also and various other signals
natural signals
but it seems
a little contrived
how is it that we can train the system
despite the fact that the objective
function we're minimizing is very
non-convex may have loads of local
minima this was a big criticism that
people were throwing at neural nets
people who had never played with neural
nets were throwing at neural nets back
in the old days say like you know you
have no guarantee that your algorithm
will converge you know uh
this is too scary i'm not gonna use it
and
and the last one is why is it that
the way we train neural nets breaks
everything that every textbook and
statistics tell you
every textbook in statistics
tells you
if you have n data points you shouldn't
have more than n parameters
because
you're going to overfit like crazy
you know you might regularize if you're
a bayesian you might throw a prior
but uh which is equivalent
uh
but
but what guarantee do you have
and with neural nets neural nets are
widely over parametrized we train neural
nets with hundreds of millions of
parameters routinely they're using
production
and the number of training samples is
nowhere near that how does that work
but it works
okay so things we can do with deep
learning today you know we can
have safer cars we can have better
medical analysis medical image analysis
systems
uh we can have pretty good language
translation far from perfect but useful
stupid chat bots
you know very good information search
retrieval and filtering google and
facebook now nowadays are completely
built around deep learning you take deep
learning out of them and they crumble
um
and you know lots of applications in
energy management and production and all
kinds of stuff manufacturing
environmental protection but we don't
have really intelligent machines we
don't have machines with common sense we
don't have
intelligent personal assistants we don't
have
you know smart chatbots we don't have
household robots you know i mean there's
a lot of things we don't know how to do
right which is why we still do research
okay so
deep learning is really about learning
representations
but really we should know in advance
what really what representations are so
i talked about the traditional
model of pattern recognition
but um
representation is really about
you know you have your raw data
you will turn it into a form that is
useful
somehow
uh ideally you'd like to turn it into a
form that's useful regardless of what
you want to do with it
sort of a useful in a general way okay
and it's not entirely clear what that
means
but at least you want to turn it into a
representation that's useful for the
tasks that you are envisioning
um
and there's been a lot of ideas over the
decades
on
sort of
general ways to
pre-process natural data in such a way
that you produce good representations of
it
i'm not going to go through the details
of this laundry list
but the things like tiling the space
doing random protection so running
projection is actually
kind of uh
you know like a monster that
rears its head periodically like every
five years and you have to whack it on
the head every time it pops up
that was the idea behind the perceptron
so the first layer of perceptron
is a layer of random projections what
does that mean
you a random projection is a random
matrix
uh which you know has a smaller output
dimension an input dimension
uh with some sort of nonlinearity at the
end right so think about a single layer
neural net with nonlinearities but the
weights are random
so you can think of this as
random projections
and a lot of people are rediscovering
that wheel periodically
claiming that it's great because you
don't have to do multi-layer training
and so he started with the perceptron
and then you know he came back
in the 60s and then he came back again
in the 1980s and then he came back again
and now he came back there's a whole
community mostly in
asia they call they call
to their neural nets where the first
layer is random they call this extreme
learning machines
okay
and it's like it's ridiculous but it
exists
they're not extreme i mean they're
extremely stupid but you know
right so i was mentioning the
compositionality of the world uh this
you know from pixels to edges to text on
motifs parts objects in text you have
characters word word groups clauses
sentences stories in speech it's the
same you have individual samples
you have you know
spectral band sound phone phonemes words
etc
you always have this kind of hierarchy
okay so
here are many attempts at dismissing the
whole idea of deep learning okay first
uh first thing and this is things that
i've heard for decades okay
from mostly theoreticians but a lot of
people and you have to know about them
because they're going to come back in
five years when people say oh deep
learning sucks
why not use supervision machines okay so
here is super vector machines here on
the top left super vector machine is
a and i'm sure many of you have heard
about kernel machines and supervisor
machines
uh who knows what this is
i mean even if it's a rough idea what
this is okay a few hands
who has no idea what a supervisor
machine is
don't be shy
i mean it's okay if you don't
okay like most people haven't raised
their hands or either
come on all the way up
cool all right
who has no idea what it is don't be shy
it's okay
all right
good um
right so here's a supervisor machine
super vector machine is a two layer
neural net it's not really a neural net
people don't like when it's formulated
this way but really you can think of it
this way it's a two layer neural net
where the first layer which is
symbolized by this function k
here uh each unit in the first layer
compares the input vector x
to one of the training samples x i's
okay so you take your training samples
let's say you have a thousand of them so
you have a thousand x size from i equal
one to a thousand
and you have some function k that is
going to compare x and x i a good
example of a function to compare the two
is you take the dot product between x
and x i and you pass the result through
like exponential minus square or
something so you get a
gaussian
response
as a function of the distance between x
and x i
okay so it's a way of comparing two two
vectors doesn't matter what it is
um
and then you take those scores coming
out of this k function that compares the
input to every sample
and you compute the weighted sum of them
and what you're going to learn are the
weights the alphas
okay so it's a two layer neural net in
which the second layer is trainable
and the first layer is fixed but in a
way you can think of the first layer as
being trained in an unsupervised manner
because it uses the data from the
training set but it only uses the x's
doesn't use the y's
it uses the data in the stupidest way
you can imagine which is you store every
x
and use every single x as the weight of
a neuron if you want
okay
that's what a supervisory machine is you
can write
a thousand page books about the cute
mathematics
behind that but the bottom line is it's
a two layer neural net where the first
layer is trained in a very super stupid
way unsupervised and the second layer is
just a linear classifier
so it's basically verified template
matching because it basically compares
the input vector to all the all the
training samples
and so it doesn't work if you want to
do like you know computer vision with
raw images if x is an image
and the x sides are a million images
from imagenet first of all for every
image you're going to have to compare it
with a million images or maybe a little
less if you're smart on how you train it
that's going to be very expensive and
the kind of comparison you're making
is basically
uh
what solves the problem the weighted sum
you're going to get at the end is really
cherry on the cake
i use that analogy too often actually um
so
you can approximate you can you can have
theorems that show that you can
approximate any function you want as
close as you want by tuning the
the k function and the alphas
and so if you talk to a theoretician
they'll tell you why do you need deep
learning i can approximate any function
i want with a kernel machine
the number of terms in that sum can be
very large and nobody tells you what
kernel function you can use
and so
that doesn't solve the problem
you can use a two-layer neural net okay
so this is the top right here
the first layer is a nonlinear function
f applied to the
product of the matrix of u0 by input
vector and then the second layer
multiplied by the second matrix
and then passes it through another
non-linearity
okay so this composite composition of
two linear and non-linear operations
again you can show that under some
conditions you can approximate any
function you want
with something like this
given that you have a large enough
vector in the middle
okay so the dimension of what comes out
of the first layer if it's high enough
potentially infinite you can approximate
any function you want as close as you
want by making this layer go to infinity
so again you talk to your theoreticians
and they tell you why do you need layers
i can approximate anything i want with
two layers
but there is an argument which is
it could be very very expensive to do it
in two layers
um
and
for some of you this may
sound familiar for most of you probably
not but um
let's say i want to design a
logic circuit okay so when you design
logic circuits right you have end gates
and
or gates and
or nand gates right you can do
everything with just nands right
negative ends um
and if you
you can show that any boolean function
can be written as a bunch of r's and a
bunch of a bunch you know a bunch of
ands
and then an or on top of this that's
called disjointed normal form dnf
so any function can be written in two
layers
the problem is that for most functions
the number of terms you need in the
middle is exponential in the size of the
input
so for example
if i give you n bits
and ask you construct a circuit that
tells me
if the number of bits that are on
in the input string
is even or odd
okay it's a simple boolean function one
or zero on the output
the number of gates that you need is
essentially exponential
in the middle if you do it in two layers
if you allow yourself to do it in
log n layers where n is number of input
bits
then it's linear
okay so you go from exponential
complexity to linear complexity if you
allow yourself to use multiple layers
it's as if you know when you write a
program
i'll tell you
write the program in such a way that
there is only two sequential steps
that are necessary to run your program
so basically your program has two
sequential instructions
you can have you can run as many
instructions as you want in your program
but they have to run in parallel most of
them
and you're only allowed two sequential
steps
okay
and the kind of instructions you have
access to are things like you know
linear combinations non-linearities like
simple things right
not like entire subprograms
so
for most
most problems
the number of intermediate values you're
going to have to compute in the first
step is going to be exponential in the
size of the input
there's only a tiny number of problems
for which you're going to be able to get
away with a non-exponential number of
midterms but if you allow your program
to
run multiple steps sequentially then all
of a sudden you know it can be much
simpler it will run slower but
uh it will take a lot less memory it
will
take a lot less stuff
resources
so people who design computer circuits
know this right you can design for
example a circuit that adds two binary
numbers and there is a very simple way
to do this which is you first you take
the first two bits you add them and then
you propagate the carry at the second
bit the second pair of bits you know
taking the carry into account that gives
you the second bit of result and then
carry you know propagate the carry and
then you do this sequentially right so
problem with this is that it takes a
time that's proportional to the size of
the of the
of the numbers that you're trying to add
so circuit designers
uh have a way of
basically pre-computing the carry that's
called carry look ahead so that the
number of steps necessary to do an
addition is actually not n it's much
less than that
okay but that that's at the expense of a
huge increase in the
complexity of the circuit
the the number like the area that it
takes on the chip
so this exchange between time and space
or between depth
and and uh
and and kind of
time is is is known
so what do we call deep
models
so you know a two layer neural net one
that has one hidden layer i don't call
that deep even though it technically
uses back prop but
you know it doesn't really learn
complex representations
so this is idea of hierarchy and deep
learning
sdn definitely are not deep
unless you learn complicated kernels but
then they're not as vms anymore
so what are good features what are good
representations
so
uh here's an example i like uh there is
something called the manifold hypothesis
and it's the fact that
natural data
so if i take a picture of this room
uh with you know
a camera with
a thousand by a thousand pixel
resolution that's one million pixels at
three million values
it leaves you can think of it as a
vector with three million uh components
among all the possible vectors with
three million components how many of
them correspond to what we would call
natural images
we can tell when we see a picture
whether it's a natural image or not
we have a model in our visual system
that tells us this looks like a real
like a real image
and we can tell but it's not so the
number of combinations of pixels that
actually are things that we that we
think of as natural images is a tiny
tiny tiny tiny tiny subset of the set of
all possible images there's way more
ways of combining random pixels in
nonsensical images and there are ways of
combining pixels into things that look
like natural images
so the manifold hypothesis is that the
set of things that
you know look natural to us live in a
low dimensional
surface inside the high dimensional
ambient space
and a good example to kind of convince
ourselves of this imagine i take lots of
pictures of a person making faces right
so the person is in front of a white
background
uh her hair not moving
and she kind of move her head around and
you know makes faces etc
the set of all images of that person so
i take a long video of that person the
set of all images of that person
lives in a low dimensional surface
so a question i have for you is what's
the dimension of that surface
order of magnitude okay
any
yes
yeah you've probably heard much field
before but
what did the person say huh what did
they say
okay so for whoever hasn't heard this
you have a shot
another shot at an answer
okay any guess
no
don't be shy
i like multiple
proposals
anyone
you can run down at your laptop but you
know
can point at you or something
okay any idea
yes
no idea it's okay
you have any idea
maybe you heard what he said
linear what does that mean
it's a 1d space
okay
a one-dimensional subspace
okay any other proposal
the idea
okay the images i'm taking are a million
pixels
okay so the ambient space is three
million dimensions
they don't change
no
and the person can move their head you
know turn around things like this but
not really move the whole body i mean
you only see the face
it's mostly centered
a thousand
okay
why
the surface area of the person right so
it's bounded by the number of pixels
occupy the other person that's for sure
that's a that's an upper bound
yes
those pixels of course are not going to
take all possible values so
that's a wider program any other idea
okay
so basically
the
dimension of that as
as you said
is bounded by the number of muscles in
the face of the person
right the number of degrees of freedom
that you observe in that person
uh is the number of muscles in the
interface
the number of independently movable
muscles right so there's three degrees
of freedom due to the fact that you can
tilt your head this way that way or that
way that's three right there
uh then there is translation
this way that way maybe this way in that
way maybe up or down that's six
and then the number of muscles in your
face right so you can
smile you can
you know pout you can do all kinds of
stuff right and you can do this you know
inapparently right you can close one eye
uh you can smile in when one direction
you know i mean so whatever independent
muscles you have
not counting the tongue because there's
tons of muscles in the
tongue and that's about 50.
maybe a little more
so
regardless it's less than 100.
okay so
the surface
locally if you want to parameterize the
surface occupied by all those pictures
move from one picture to another
it's a surface with less than 100
parameters that determine the position
of a point on that surface
of course it's a highly non-linear
surface
it's not like this beautiful calibrio
manifold here but
but it's a it is a surface nonetheless
of course the answer was in the side so
you know
so what you'd like is an ideal feature
extractor to be able to disentangle the
explanatory factors of variation of what
you're observing
right so the different aspects of my
face you know it's not just i move my
muscles and i move my head around
each of those is an independent factor
variation i can also remove my glasses
um
you know
the lighting could change
that's another set of you know variable
variables and what you'd like is a
representation that basically
individually represents each of those
factors or variations
so if there is a criterion to satisfy in
learning good representations
it's that it's finding independent
explanatory factors of variation of the
data that you're looking at
and the bottom line is that nobody has
any idea how to do this okay
but that would be the
ultimate goal of
representation learning
and we basically are